مدينه اسطنبول ستقرر مصير من يحكم تركيا
ولاجل ذلك حرص الرئيس التركي اردوغان
وخصمه كمال
على اختيار هذه المدينه التاريخيه لمخاطبه
جمهور الطرفين اردوغان اختار مدرج مطار
اتاتورك الدولي القديم في اسطنبول حيث
تدفق الالاف من مناصريه للاستماع الى
خطابه الذي اكد فيه مجددا على ان اسطنبول
اذا قالت نعم فسينتصر بالتاكيد حسب تعبير
اردوغان طبعا كما اختار اوغلو الجانب
الاسيوي للمدينه وعقد تجمعه في حديقه تطل
على بحر مرمره ليخاطب مناصريه حيث يبلغ
عدد الناخبين في مدينه اسطنبول مشاهدينا
اكثر من 11 مليونا وهنا تتاكد اهميه هذه
المدينه لحسم الانتخابات كيف لا وهي التي
حسمت انتخابات البلديه الماضيه لصالح اك
على حساب اردوغان وفريقه طبعا ايضا
الدعايه الانتخابيه في هذه الانتخابات
شهدت اساليب جديده بعيده عن الاساليب
التقليديه التي اعتدنا عليها في
الانتخابات ولفتت الانظار سواء كان في
الشارع او عبر شاشات التلفزه او مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي على سبيل المثال كما
نشاهد في هذه اللافته التي تظهر رسما
كاريكاتوريا لمرشح المعارضه لرئاسه
للرئاسه طبعا رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
اوغلو وهو كما نشاهدون بهذه الصوره على
هيئه سبايدر مان بينما اختارت رئيسه حزب
الجيد ميرال
اسلوبا مميزا في حملتها الدعائيه وادخلت
ما يعرف بالجرافيكس اللافلتر الرئيسيه
لحملاتها حيث وضعت الصوره صورتها هنا مع
مؤسس تركيا مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى
كمال اتاتورك وصورا تعبر عن مواطنين من
مختلف الفئات مع عباره تركيا ستكتب
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات